our first guest is here for a behind the
scenes which is one of my favorite games
because it celebrates the body of work
and gives us things that we wouldn't
hear elsewhere so I'm always there for
that too Queen Latifah everybody all
right this is something we called behind
the scenes
all right Living Single
I was on that it was so much fun working
with everyone we we did something that
wasn't on TV exactly and it was so much
fun and um yeah like a bunch of kids
found it during covid and then after
that now it's on HBO you know what I
mean and what are we doing on HBO
I was like wait a minute Game of Thrones
and Living Single
[Applause]
I would do anything with I would do
anything with the cast of Living Single
we we're on like a group chat to this
day really we our group chat is a show
we cracked so many jokes on there and
talk so much smack and this and and
Erica is just so funny oh my God they
are so funny and so yeah I would I would
okay good let's just get the tax
matriculate them into a script we can do
the reunion right here on the show let's
do this and we have this uh new
technology we can make it happen
all right I want to talk about Black
Rain the album that you won the Grammy
for that was probably my favorite album
to make dark album to make lost my
brother motorcycle accident I'm 22 he's
24.
went in the studio leave me alone
everyone left me alone
and let me just make just take pour my
heart into this album and make music and
from it came records like just another
day you and I T Y and the song I
dedicated to him called Winky's theme
which I remember being in a restaurant
called the Bowery bar everybody used to
go there and Mariah Carey happened to be
there that night and walked over to me
like hey girl they're before the grace
of God
foreign
walked over and sang My Song
I was like what
in the Whitney world of I mean this is
big singers you know singing your song
to you so
um I call it Black Rain because I felt
like I'm a queen I'm black I'm raining
but it was also a dark time that I was
working through so it's always thank God
for music I love the music that is so
awesome we have fun despite the tough
times it was it was great what else you
got that's fast I'm slow the Queen
Latifah talk show I mean well man I'm
tired I'm tired
I remember that that was like 2 000 or
something like that and it was very
exciting because you know we get to have
someone who's the vice president running
for president
um
a lot of secret service around I don't
know these Secret Service things are
kind of fun in one way but like you
trapped in the other way they lock it
down they lock it down Chicago your
oscar-nominated
oh yes
doing Chicago was great because Rob
Marshall directed it and you had all
these big stars in it but it was so cool
watching Rob Rob was like everybody
check their egos at the door Rob was
like I got you babe I got I have you
don't worry about anything and we would
come to work on our days off
people would come just to watch other
people shoot scenes that's how beautiful
this movie was and how an awful thing I
mean yeah like almost never you created
a masterpiece I was part of it I was
happy to be part of it another
musical
give me some yeah another Musical that I
love Hairspray the 2007 version
what's the first thought that comes to
mind
I just got to be careful in blonde wigs
oh I don't agree the lips bring out
something in me that um oh that way yeah
ciao what does it bring out I don't know
there's a little something happening
that makes me want to get a little loose
uh
blonde wigs I see y'all out there yeah
I'm trying not to look lions do have
more fun apparently so I mean this
blonde did she make too much fun of
girls having The Best Time Ever girls
trip
I love it so much
[Applause]
isn't that the best poster look at that
come on that was so much fun we had so
much fun making that movie it was just
CR you know the funny thing is I hadn't
met Tiffany haddish I didn't know she
was gonna be the the girl the craziest
friend out of all the friends and I'm
taking a flight to New Orleans and this
girl is behind me like cracking jokes
with the guy next to her who she does
not know hey cutie pie hey you looking
good daddy let me slide across you let
me get across and she like sits on the
guy's lap to get over to her chair does
not know this man we get off the plane
and I'm like oh the next day you're the
girl from the plane
[Applause]
you are gone I love this okay now your
film on Netflix it was the number one
film
um the week of September 5th it had 30
million viewers
um End of the Road who knew
that you could do that with all that
hair
in New Mexico I was like I'm burning up
it was hot this it was hot it was hot
New Mexico is hot I loved shooting this
movie and I remember
um you know I used to think well I mean
we're all here in New York we know what
it's like when the Gucci's put on the
fireworks here and how amazing that is
and I thought it was the best fireworks
in in the America but when you're in New
Mexico up in the hills of Albuquerque
and you look out over a 30 mile Vista
and there's nothing but fireworks all
across the pla it was the most amazing
thing I'd ever seen in my life none of
us lifelong memory it was amazing it was
amazing so thank you for the support on
that film and you know we'll be coming
back with more of them you know I hope
so thank you
equalizer airs Sunday at 8pm on CBS
[Music]